connovaciones en la plaza roja saludo de
armas y el himno nacional
Rusia celebró el día de la Victoria
contra la Alemania nazi en la Segunda
Guerra Mundial
el 9 de mayo de 1945 el ejército rojo
tomó Berlín
y dio el golpe definitivo contra el
fascismo
hoy en medio de la guerra en Ucrania
Vladimir Putin señaló a las potencias
occidentales de repetir la historia del
nazismo
las élites globalistas occidentales
están enfrentando a las personas entre
sí y dividiendo a la sociedad provocando
conflictos sangrientos y golpes de
estado sembrando odio rusofobia
nacionalismo agresivo destruyendo los
valores familiares tradicionales que
hacen a las personas humanas
Putin elogió a los altos mandos
militares que participan en la invasión
a Ucrania presentes en la ceremonia e
instó a los rusos a estar Unidos en lo
que calificó como una guerra Sagrada
contra occidente
una retórica diametralmente opuesta
sobre la naturaleza de la guerra a 800
kilómetros de Moscú en kiev donde el
presidente de Ucrania voló dimir
selenski se reunió con la presidenta de
la comisión europea Úrsula Fender Legend
en el encuentro por el festejo el día de
Europa también en conmemoración por la
derrota nazi en el continente se
discutió sobre la integración de Ucrania
la Unión Europea y asuntos de defensa
así como nuevas sanciones contra Rusia
la sociedad rusa es Sangrienta y apoyan
ciertas acciones radicales siempre están
contentos con las cifras de Muertos
el festejo por el 9 de mayo estuvo
ensombrecido por una Nueva Ola de
ataques con misiles por parte de Rusia
contra varias ciudades ucranianas